Lux je hebt vandaag
echt 1 unieke prestatie
geleverd voor kinderen in palestina
waar kwam dat iniciatief vandaan
ik zag beelden op het jasje
nou en toen dacht ik dit is gewoon te zielig
ja
ja dus en toen dacht jij
ik GA deze actie doen
ja is 1 hele mooie actie wat was je record
10.000 ook 10.000 keer hoog
en vandaag HEB je meer dan 10.000 keer hoog gehouden
ja echt 1 mooie presentatie
ik HEB je ook live meegenomen op mijn eigen kanaal
zal ik uit dat terugkijken is wel heel leuk
maar de kijkers hebben zeker genoot van jou
het GA je goed is echt 1 hele mooie prestatie van jou
en kinderen moeten kinderen blijven
en kinderen moeten altijd blijven lachen
ja toch luxe high five
top man succes